today on the matt wall show leaked
internal videos show that my children's
book johnny the walrus has traumatized
and triggered amazon's employees they
are literally in tears over it and it's
the greatest moment of my career we'll
talk about it today also conservative
accounts on twitter see huge spikes and
followers right as it's announced that
elon musk is buying the company what's
going on there and more disturbing
information about the children's book
quote unquote from the american academy
of pediatrics that pushes chemical
castration on nine-year-olds plus a
nascar driver is sent to sense
sensitivity training for posting a
racist meme but was the meme actually
racist and our daily cancellation more
leaked videos this time it's
administrators and leftist activists
needing to game plan protests against my
speech tonight at wisconsin superior but
why are school administrators helping to
plan protests we'll talk about all that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
if your retirement account has been
heavy on stocks for a while i have some
great news for you you've won the value
of your ira or 401k has likely ballooned
thanks to the longest bull market run in
u.s history but after every bull run
comes a recession and right now stock
valuations are at historic highs only
seen before the great depression and the
dot-com crash in the face of teetering
global stability stock volatility
volatility is way up so maybe it's time
to take some of your chips off the table
secure your winnings and your future
with gold from birch gold that's right
birch gold will help you convert those
gains you have on paper into a real
physical asset oh yeah and it'll be in a
tax sheltered account which means uncle
sam can't get its grubby paws on it get
started now text walsh to 98 98 98 with
thousands of satisfied customers and an
eight-plus rating with the better
business bureau birch gold can help you
protect your savings text walsh to 98
98.98 to get a free info kit on gold
there is no obligation to get this info
so text walsh again to 98 98 98 to
protect at least some of your winnings
with gold
my friends
my sweet babies i've had some proud
moments in my career so far even back
when i was screaming at the dashboard in
my car while parked in a walmart parking
lot which is where i did a lot of my
shows back then for some reason but even
then
on occasion there would be a milestone
which to me was significant since then
there have been other personal
achievements which meant a lot to me but
nothing in my career can come close to
this to the knowledge that my
best-selling children's book johnny the
walrus traumatized terrified and
triggered their own words amazon's
employees this is the pinnacle the
summit uh it's all downhill from here
i'm afraid
so yesterday my friend lives with tiktok
released uh the video from an amazon
internal meeting where
employees discussed complained about and
consoled each other over
my books actually my books plural not
just johnny the walrus the whole thing
is so perfect so on the nose that you
might suspect i scripted it and staged
it all myself um it begins with one of
the leaders of the meeting
talking about the trauma
that my book about walruses has caused
let's listen
it's been a very traumatic experience
for transgender amazonians and our
transgender customers
what i don't want to come out of this
is
um
slamming the books team uh with a bunch
of tickets they are already aware of
this
there are things in the space that are
happening
i take it back um i could not have
scripted this because if i had i never
would have included the line
transgender amazonians
that would have seemed too absurd too
contrived it's the kind of lunacy that
only an authentic leftist in his natural
environment could come up with
transgender amazonian sounds like some
kind of
mythical character
and
well if the shoe fits
also note how he says that the books
team is quote aware and quote there are
things in this space that are happening
in other words they are actively trying
to suppress the book that's what he's
saying unsuccessfully very
unsuccessfully as it turns out uh
because right now the book is is just
surging on the charts it's in the top
five in the top five for for a day but
they're trying and it's the fact that
they they've been so unsuccessful and
that i was able to figure out a way to
navigate the system a system designed to
make sure that people like me fail that
makes them all the more enraged
as as we'll see a little bit later on
for now though let's uh keep on
listening to this clip
johnny the walrus is
a bit of a problematic book
uh not a bit it is
it is not a bit of a problem it's one
hell of a problem
um and i would preface this about what
the book's about but the customer we're
going to listen to
does a great job
i need to keep a running list here of
superlatives to add to the
book cover when we do a second printing
or actually a third printing because uh
the first printing sold out in a day if
you hadn't heard so he's already given
me some good ones problematic traumatic
and one hell of a problem that last
one's especially great i hope that i
want that on my tombstone when i die one
hell of a problem the customer who
called in to complain one of many
complaints we're told so we're told this
is kind of like a a representative
sample
but this customer certainly agrees with
all those assessments about me and about
the book and has a whole lot more to say
about it let's listen
i just checked
your website and
the book
is
still up on there i hate to tell you but
it says that the book that it is shipped
and sold from you
it is by
matt walsh
it is teaching kids to
kill
well to bully
transgenders
yeah to bully them into committing
suicide the lgbtqia
especially
transgenders
the story is about a kid
who likes to pretend he's different
things and one day he pretends he's a
walrus
and
the community tells him
he either has to be a human
or he has to be a walrus or they're
going to kill him he can't be both he
can't pretend anymore now the author
matt walsh just tweeted this yesterday
morning at 804 a.m
i now have the number one
anti-lgbt book in the country
any further criticism of me or my book
is homophobic
checkmate
you are telling a manual
how to teach kids to bully other kids to
commit suicide
you know what honestly i'm i'm really
mad because i have a
i have a sibling that who is member of
the lgbtq so i'm really mad as well
right now
now if i was inclined to call people
karen's um
i'd certainly say that this person fits
the bill i don't call people that
because it's an anti-white racial slur
so instead we'll just stick with calling
her a shrill hectoring wench
maybe the view should give her a call
she'd be perfect i think as a coast she
might actually be someone from the view
she also lies about the content of the
book claiming that i instruct kids to
kill or at least bully transgenders in
this in this rather dark and gritty
reimagining of my original story she
says that um in my book johnny the
walrus you know johnny is told by the
community that they'll kill him if he
doesn't stop pretending to be a walrus
none of that actually happens in the
book i mean i it's been a little while
since i wrote it i i admit
i'll go back and check but i don't think
i don't remember including any lines in
there about killing transgenders or the
community telling johnny that stop
pretending to be a walruser will kill
you
that that's not in there
in fact nothing like that happens and it
makes me concerned for the woman's
health you know i know that um
you can actually get uh and this is true
this is a medical fact i think that you
can get um like brain worms from
exposure to too much cat litter and so
i'm concerned that this cat lady may be
suffering from that condition i mean
jokes on the worms though in that case
because they made it up to her head and
looked around and found out the place
was empty
um she then says that that i called my
own book the number one anti-lgbt book
in the country in fact i didn't say that
i called it because it was and will
always be
in my heart the num the number one lgbt
book in the country not anti-lgbt book
so she lied about that too or
hallucinated it meanwhile the amazon
employee on the phone listens to all
this and nods along in agreement
you know he's angry too he says
by this book that the lady just made up
and keep in mind that that amazon itself
they are playing this complaint for the
other employees
and endorsing it
i mean they said up front they like
agree with this that this is a good
description of the book while she just
makes up a version of the book that
doesn't exist
but we somehow have yet to make it to
the best parts
things get more emotional in a second
video as the employees continue to
lament the many ways in which i abused
committed violence against
their algorithms listen
it's bad faith it's basically abuse of
amazon systems and
they're
they're they're intentionally like it
when i say they i mean like matt walsh
and his publishing publishing company
and other people like him are taking
advantage of amazon and how the amazon
algorithms work
to promote their particular brand of
hate
and harm on the community
i have taken advantage of amazon without
amazon's clear and affirmative consent i
have used and abused and manhandled its
algorithms
this is the worst case of algorithmic
abuse the world has ever seen
and we aren't done i mean if you're if
you're worried that so far they've cried
over one of my trolling schemes but have
neglected to mention my other ones don't
worry because they do get around to that
also
the other part of this that is equally
disturbing is um
he matt walsh is getting ready to
release
um i believe
um a book called what is a woman and
there's also a
documentary
that comes with it
um
jamie lee shared some information with
me about the movie
um the documentary that's going along
with it but people are already talking
about it he tricked
it was very much
that style tricking transgender people
into participating
not understanding what they were
participating in and it's called what is
a woman
um one man's journey to answer the
question i mean like does it like let's
just back up for a second and say does a
man even belong in this conversation no
he doesn't but guess what we're not it's
not even on sale yet and it's
number one in women's studies
and and number one in the other
categories um that it's available in as
well
so this is chief mansplaining
chief mansplainer another superlative
first of all how do you know
that i'm not a woman
i mean what is a woman in order to make
that kind of criticism against what is a
woman you first need to be able to tell
me what is a woman but you
and that's exactly why the film and book
exist
which you can find out more about uh
when you go to what is woman.com second
this is no way to speak
to a or about a best-selling women's
studies scholar can i just say
finally we get to the grand finale and
we got to play this this is the
emotional crescendo of the story
when ultimately breaking under the
psychological stress
the guy leading the meeting
begins to weep
watch this and don't laugh
okay this is serious stuff so don't
laugh you you heartless bullies
watch
exploiting our systems right our systems
aren't
like they're not set up to catch
you know they can you know the
self-publishing authors they can
categorize their books
however they want
um
and so um
yeah i want to i just
i'm sorry
i i want to preface this with i want to
preface this with i also saw someone
mention that this is really tough
content and
if you're transgender if you're gender
non-binary
take you know and this is super
triggering and this is super it like it
would like i would understand if you
needed to leave this is for education
for people
who don't get it who don't understand
and i would understand if if this was a
lot but equally
i want folks to know
um
that we that we're doing this because
this really matters
i understand um i also understand you
know i understand if my book written on
cardboard for preschoolers
about a boy who pretends to be a walrus
is too distressing and disturbing for
you
you know i understand
i understand in other words if you're
mentally ill
i understand i sympathize well actually
i don't really sympathize and come to
think of it i don't really understand
either but i acknowledge it anyway and i
hope you get the counseling you need
or i hope you banish yourself to an
island in the pacific somewhere i'll
take either option really though i'd
prefer the latter because
your cry bully narcissism is a scourge a
plague
a cancer on this country
now i want to speak now
finally directly to
these employees at amazon
you're obviously paying
close attention to what i say and do so
i know you'll see this and hear it
and i want you to hear me when i when i
say what needs to be said here this
would be perhaps the most important
message that you ever hear in your life
it's something you should have been told
years ago but never were and i'll tell
you now and here it is
it's not my job
to cater to
your feelings
i in fact
do not care
about your feelings
because
your feelings are wrong
did you know that feelings can be wrong
because they can
now you might have been told different
when you were little
but they lied to you so feelings can be
wrong
and when you feel sad angry upset
traumatized triggered
scandalized whatever
about a children's book that teaches
little kids to accept themselves for who
they truly are
like who they really are who they
biologically are rather than following a
delusion when that makes you feel bad
and icky inside your feelings are wrong
you should not feel that way
you are wrong for feeling that way
you're the problem not me
you should apologize to me for being so
damned weird
and annoying and unreasonable
i mean you think that women have penises
you think that kids should be chemically
castrated and sterilized
you think that the books that we should
be selling to kids and that you should
be selling the kids on amazon are the
ones that encourage them to sterilize
and castrate themselves
that's what you think that's how you
feel and that's why your feelings are
not valid your opinions are irrelevant
you should feel ashamed
but you don't and that's the whole
problem
i'm not the problem
you are
you freaks
glad we could have this talk
and thank you for driving my book all
the way to the top five overall on
amazon again
you've inspired me to write more
children's books so stay tuned
and we'll get now to our five headlines
[Music]
you know the thing about the left is
that they hate everything that is good
in the world um and that includes and
especially includes meat
and you know but when the supply chain
inflation cause meat prices to soar
their response then isn't to solve the
supply chain inflation it's to tell you
that it's the perfect opportunity to
switch from juicy delicious and
nutritious meat to something called
lentils or worse another priority seems
to be getting you to stop eating meat
and start eating bugs instead people
like bill gates and outlets like time
magazine tell us eating bugs is the
solution to all of our problems i mean
they're not bill gates is not eating
bugs i guarantee that but he's saying
that you should
and frankly i find it disgusting and
i've realized something it's not enough
to not eat bugs you have to be anti-bug
eating
and that requires action against the
bug-eating movement the best way to do
that is to eat more meat so i've decided
to double down on my meat intake and i'm
inviting you to join me i just
subscribed to the cowboy box from good
ranchers which contains almost uh 10
pounds of all-american beef if you're
worried about the supply chain or
inflation increasing the price of meat
over time the solution is not lentils
the answer is subscribing to good
ranchers they lock in your price for
life once you subscribe and they only
source from american farm so please
don't let the vegans and the bug eaters
win we need to double down on eating
meat literally so go to goodranchers.com
and enter promo code walsh to check out
for 30 off your order that's codewalsh
at goodranchers.com for 30 off your
first order
um one other note about this that i
think it's important to point out
because we played most of the the clips
from that uh amazon meeting but there
are others you know
some some other some other pieces that
uh we that we didn't play and
in this the one theme that you keep
hearing over and over again and that you
hear in those clips and and some of the
other parts of it is just how yeah
they're upset about the book they're
upset about
what's in it they're upset about the
message they're upset about everything
but
they're
what really gets them
is how according to them i gamed the
system i manipulated the system i abused
it you know
all of these things they're talking
about the system and the algorithm like
it's a like it's a person like i've
committed assault against an actual
human being
and but how did i gain the system all i
did was write the book on cardboard
and then put it on amazon
that's all that we did
i i wish i could say there was something
more clever and devious going on
but there isn't
and so when they say i think this is
another mask off moment it's very
revealing because when they say
game the system or manipulating system
what they're admitting is that the
system is designed to make sure that
people like me
don't succeed in it that's what that's
what they're admitting
and so when they see that uh someone
like myself has a bestselling book
especially a best-selling children's
book and especially a best-selling
children's book that um that that is
meant to be an in an antidote
to the leftist indoctrination that goes
on in in a lot of other kids books when
they see that it's like no this is not
amazon's not supposed to do that
because amazon isn't for you that's what
they're saying to me
and anyone like me
so quite revealing in fact
uh all right let's
go here from the daily wire it says
the same day elon musk announced he had
reached an agreement with twitter to
purchase a company for 44 billion
conservative users reported they began
seeing large increases in their follower
accounts and engagement one of the most
significant factors motivating musk's
purchase of twitter was his concern over
censorship and speech suppression on the
platform
throughout the last two weeks as he's
pressed his bid to purchase the company
has indicated that one of his top
priorities will be reversing
heavy-handed content moderation policies
and lifting algorithms that may be
unfairly targeting some tweets and
accounts based on their political views
um
and
now there are this
and this is something a lot of
conservatives have noticed
not just a few you know um and i've
noticed it also
that's quite interesting that literally
on the on the day
when they announced
that this deal was going to happen and
it hasn't been finalized i think they
have until
they have until october i think or
november to finalize it
but on the day that it was officially
announced
conservative accounts including my own
saw massive spikes and followers
and then but on the on the other side of
it
a lot of leftist accounts if you could
track that like msnbc hosts and cnn
hosts they saw their follower accounts
dip and i'm not exactly sure why you
know it's it's not clear to me why
that's happening
um it could be a good thing
i mean one one possible reason to
explain this is that um
there were things that they were doing
to suppress conservative accounts
talking about systems that are designed
to make sure that we don't succeed in
them
and so there are things that they were
doing to suppress that
um and to stop people from you know if
you're a conservative account to stop
people from finding you from following
you there
they had certain systems in place
to suppress those accounts
and then as soon as this deal was
announced
now they're trying to cover their tracks
because that's the thing it's not as
though elon musk has taken over twitter
today
that's not going to officially happen
for several more months
so you would think you shouldn't start
seeing these changes yet
and if we are seeing the changes then
maybe they're they're trying to they're
getting rid of all these things and
trying to cover their tracks
so that's one possibility
um
it's also possible there's something a
little bit more sinister going on here
and i'm not sure what exactly that would
be but it does just it actually makes me
a little bit nervous when i see this
given that elon musk has not taken over
the company yet it's still in the hands
of the people who were running it
two days ago
and yet we're seeing this wild spike in
in uh in followers for conservative
accounts i don't know what exactly it is
is it is it bots
are they kind of behind the scenes
flooding the place with bots to try to
sabotage the platform before elon musk
takes over could be something like that
i don't know what it is
but things are a foot that's for sure
um
also from the daily wire
says leftist tears were literally
flowing at twitter headquarters on
monday after elon musk's offer to buy
the social media platform was accepted
um as one high-ranking employee
reportedly broke down and cried during a
staff meeting about the purchase so
there is a theme that we're seeing right
now in the show of people at big tech
companies crying because things aren't
going the way that they want
i mean these are grown adults weeping
at their jobs
because of this
on tuesday political reported that
twitter's top lawyer vijaya
i think that's how you pronounce her
first name vijaya vijaya gad called a
virtual meeting among policy and legal
teams that she oversees to discuss how
musk would impact the company
it's political reported quote gad cried
during the meeting as she expressed
concerns about how the company could
change according to three people
familiar with the meeting she
acknowledged that there are significant
uncertainties about what the company
will look like under musk's leadership
political also reported that gad who has
worked with twitter since 2011 is the
key executive charged with overseeing
twitter's trust and safety legal and
public policy functions
the attorney is apparently so well
respected within the company that she
has seen internally as twitter's moral
authority
uh she was the one who was primarily
behind apparently you know reportedly
primarily behind
um
suspending the new york post for the
hunter biden
story
and if she's running the trust and
safety whatever council commission over
at the at twitter then that means that
she's ultimately the one behind making
these decisions about who gets banned
who gets suspended
you know babylon b gets suspended
for saying that males are men
that's that's her
and come to think of it actually
um maybe she has reason to cry because
the thing ultimately that i'm sure she's
crying about is that she's she thinks
she's going to lose her job
which i hope to god she does
i mean elon musk far be it for me to
tell him how to how to do his job once
he's running twitter but i think this is
the first thing he needs to do is go in
there you find peop people like this
and you get rid of them
um
because these are you know even though
there are algorithms and systems and
everything that are put in place there
are actual human beings behind all of
this and there are human beings at
twitter who decided to turn it into
you know
a left you know
decided to weaponize it
for left-wing ideology and punish
people on ideological grounds
and she's one of them and you just gotta
you gotta get you gotta get rid of her
um and that's probably why she's crying
because she knows her days are number
numbered at twitter as well they should
be
uh the women over at the view are also
not quite crying but uh nearly on the
verge of tears and the view chimed in on
all this and and they have a take um on
all of this that is about as tedious as
you have come to expect from these
ladies let's
on twitter it is predominantly
straight white men so when elon musk
says wow this is about free speech it
seems to me that it's about free speech
of straight
white men and so let them have it let
them just go at it i enjoyed the block
button on twitter
i think it has a real outsized influence
in our world because politicians and
celebrities are on it
i mean tedious is really the word that
just comes to mind for that
this is the
they are themselves and i think many
leftists especially media have gotten to
this point where they are themselves
basically they are algorithms they're
walking algorithms
barely even humans anymore capable of of
of critical
thought
you know they're programmed a certain
way and so the minute something happens
that they don't like well this is all
about straight white men and this
there's no of course it should go
without saying there's no evidence of
that whatsoever
i mean
elon musk has never said anything that
would lead you to believe
that um he wants to favor straight white
men and this that this is what this is
really all about
she says that oh no he only believes in
free speech for straight white men so
what he's gonna he's gonna take over
twitter and the new rule at twitter is
going to be if you're a straight white
man you can say whatever you want but if
you're not then here here are the
moderation policies
i highly doubt that he's going to put us
a rule like that in place and he's never
said anything that could lead anyone to
actually believe that
but this is how she's programmed
and she's not capable of actually
analyzing events and um arriving at the
conclusions that way
all right i want to move to this i
mentioned this on the show yesterday but
now we have more information courtesy of
a daily wire report
and i'll just read from it it says uh
can girls get erections
a co-author of the american academy of
pediatrics newest guide to puberty not
only says yes they can but that such
occurrences are completely normal
in response to these claims some
pro-family groups are slamming the quote
gender diverse book as insanity
on april 19th the aap issued a new guide
title that we told you about this
yesterday uology a puberty guide for
everybody targeted towards uh children
ages 9 through 13 years old
and this is a book
as we mentioned yesterday
um a supposedly a children's book 9-13
and it is one of the top selling
children's books on amazon right now
i mean mine's above it right now but as
well it should be but it's one of the
top selling children's books um one
pediatrician who helped write the book
explained in a radio interview that the
group of professional doctors wanted to
purposefully include chapters explaining
radical gender ideology to children dr
catherine lowe told npr with this book
we're trying to change that language to
be more inclusive
she claimed with traditional puberty
education whether it's in schools or in
books we talk about how girls get their
periods and boys get erections but some
girls for example transgender girls
might not get their periods they need to
understand about erections and those
changes in their bodies so we wanted to
fill this void in puberty education so
that kids regardless of their gender can
see themselves in a book and learn about
their bodies
um
and we as we discussed yesterday they
not only talk about girls getting
erections but they also
um in especially in one of the one of
the chapters
i haven't read the entire book but all
we need to know is about the one chapter
uh about what happens if puberty doesn't
feel right
and in that book they
promote
hormones puberty blockers chemical
castration sterilization
because that's what those drugs do by
the way that's what those drugs are
these are chemical castration drugs and
they sterilize kids
and this is we have to keep emphasizing
it the american academy of pediatrics
putting a book out like that
and of course they say this is all about
uh well this is about representing we
want kids to feel
represented we want them to feel seen
you know we want a kid who's who's
already
transgender we want them to read this
book and
and feel seen and represented by it
but that's not the point of the book at
all of course
and even if that was the point
and the purpose of the book that would
be bad enough because there's actually
no such thing as a transgender kid
but no in fact it's not about
representing or making them feel seen
it's about
recruiting more kids
into that
world
it's about promoting transgenderism
it's not like let's take the kids who
are already transgender quote unquote
and uh give them this book they can read
it's let's make a book that creates this
is about creating more transgender kids
which as we have seen over the last
several years
is very easy to do because kids and
especially if you're targeting them
right on the cusp of puberty
and hormones are raging and their bodies
are changing and their minds going
haywire and all these things are
happening we all went through it when we
were kids
and they're confused and they don't know
exactly what's happening and they feel
very uncomfortable in their body they
feel very awkward and then you come in
and you say well i'll i'll help you
understand what's happening here and in
fact i'll give you an escape valve
here's a little and there's there's no
side effects nothing bad can happen
here's a little button you can push
that'll put all this on pause so you can
escape it and you don't have to deal
with it
that's the message to kids now just
think about that
you're going to kids and you're saying
well puberty is very difficult
and your body as you know it is going to
change drastically
and and and oftentimes in ways that that
you don't really like at first
and um but we're going to give you a
choice
you can have all that icky stuff happen
with your body or you can have it not
happen at all
and so many kids because they don't
understand and they don't know what
they're doing they're going to say well
i'll take the option to not have that
happen to my body
and then the propagandists over american
academy pediatrics will say well see
there's there's proof right there that
there are so many transgender kids this
is why we need more books like this
it is so insidious what they're doing
this is from sports illustrated it says
nascar announced tuesday that denny
hamlin will be required to complete a
sensitivity training course that must
begin by the end of the week according
to a league spokesperson the cup series
driver made a social media post on
monday using an anti-asian meme from the
television show family guide toward kyle
larson regarding his final lap move
in uh sunday's talladega super speedway
and this is he's being accused of racism
it was where we're being told and this
was sports illustrated said in their
headlines a racist joke that that um
hamlin made a racist joke about this
other nascar driver hamlin tweeted i
took down a post i made earlier today
after reading some of the comments it
was a poor choice of memes and i saw how
it was offensive it came across totally
wrong i apologize
larson who was half japanese and the
reigning cup series champion made a move
in his final turn that helped him finish
fourth overall in the race however this
move was an aggressive one
that uh caused a crash
and okay so you have
larsen
half japanese does something during the
race causes a crash and then denny
hamlin uh another nascar driver tweets
out this meme kind of like making a joke
about it from family guy and in fact we
have the meme before it was deleted
and uh he was sent off to sensitivity
training camp before that here's here's
what he posted let's watch it here
how much signal i need to cut across
eight lane none i turn now good luck
everybody else
i think it's funny um
you know there was a there was a a time
when you could i mean that's family guy
that's not a that's not a show from
from 70 years ago so like not all that
long ago you could make jokes like that
so here's a couple of things
we're being so this is a this is a
racist joke and of course
hamlin's apologized for it and he's
calling the sensitivity training and all
the rest of it
um
but
maybe we should ask like is that
actually a racist joke and
the answer is no
it in fact does not
okay
and i know this may be very shocking for
lots of people to hear
but a joke a a racial
joke
is not automatically racist it's not
okay because racism racist these are
this is a word that means something and
what it means is that if you're a racist
person if you're making a racist
statement
then it's a statement that another
race
um or
or ethnicity is
inferior to you
like you you don't like them they're
inferior
and um and you're better than them
that's that's that's that's what racism
is
there's nothing in that
little meme there that even implies
anything like that
it doesn't imply that he hates asian
people it doesn't imply that he thinks
asian people are inferior to him
but yeah it's a it's a it's a it's a
stereotype so you're just having a
little bit of fun with the stereotype
and it's slightly edgy and yeah it might
be a little bit it could be offensive
that's the other thing that might be
shocking for people to hear a joke can
be racial
and even offensive i mean i don't think
it's offensive but it could be if it
could be racial and offensive but not
racist
if you can believe it
so if you want to call that offensive
that's a little bit offensive
maybe
it's not racist
and and here's the other thing
it is a sign of progress
when you can make jokes like that
okay when you can make racial jokes
and ethnic jokes
that's a sign of progress in society
so kind of like where we were
in say the 90s
which i which which right now is
the
has to i guess be the pinnacle of uh
of
interracial relations in america
because
you could make jokes like that
and no one really got offended and
everyone yeah different people making
jokes about other people and uh and
that's it it was just a joke you'd laugh
about it that's a sign of progress
it's just like if someone if you're if
you're friends with someone
you can make jokes about them
that people who are not their friends
can't make
so it's actually a sign of affection and
familiarity when you can kind of joke
around with your friends it's especially
the case with guys
uh maybe a little bit less so with women
but that's a general principle when you
could joke around with someone make
jokes that uh maybe in another context
from somebody else would be offensive
but this is a sign of you're familiar
your friends it's actually a show of
affection
and so when you're in a society where
people of different ethnicities and
races can make jokes about each other
and it's all in good fun and you just
kind of laugh about it that's progress
and so the fact that we have now reached
a point
where we cannot make any jokes at all
on racial grounds
um that means that we've regressed
because we used to be able to do that
and now we can't that's regression
that's not a sign that uh that race
relations have improved it's a sign of
the opposite happening
all right uh what else do we got here
okay i want to show you this because uh
before we get to the comment section i
think this tweet right here sums up this
sums up the state of journalism in the
year 2022 can we play this put this up
on the screen this is a bbc um
journalist
who's visiting america i guess
and encountered something at walmart
that they found to be
just quite uh scandalous here it is
so this is uh
padraig
belton
and he tweeted this hi from america
where walmart doesn't have a plug
adapter for my uk laptop but on the
other hand
i can buy a rifle and ammunition
and then he's got a picture of uh what
he calls a rifle and ammunition which is
just sitting there behind glass
at
walmart now
not only can you just buy the rifle but
uh it even this just makes it all the
worse
it's the rifle is uh it's just like you
buy it in a box
and you could buy it for 28 bucks
actually i had to get over to walmart
they're selling rifles for 28
and uh and even if if you zoom in you
can even see on the box it says ages 10
and up so they're just selling rifles to
to 10 euro you're telling me a 10 year
old kid can walk in the walmart and buy
a rifle for 28
oh but then oh no well that's actually
that's see that's a bb gun that's why it
says red rider
so not only can this journalist not
identify a bb gun when he sees it
even though it says it on the box
um but also somehow he's never seen a
christmas story
i mean anyone who's seen a christmas how
have you not not only should you have
seen a christmas story but i i thought
everybody in the english-speaking world
has seen that movie
at least 75 times
so that should have been your first clue
and even if you haven't seen that movie
um
and and so you didn't know that the red
rider bb gun plays very prominently
in that story you should still be able
to look at that and tell there are there
are context clues like the fact that
it's 28 dollars
and then you could just read the box and
this is a journalist
this is how inquisitive this journalist
is this is how good he is at
investigating things that he couldn't
even read a box
and it shows not only that this is a you
know journalists who who
don't even do five seconds of additional
research before posting something and
making a claim like this
but this also shows like why why did he
tweet this
in the first place
why did he see that and actually think
that these are real rifles that are
being sold to kids for 28 bucks it's
because
this is how he sees america
like for him he saw that and it
confirmed his priors
he saw that and he thought oh yeah well
this is this is exactly what i've heard
about america
they just hand out rifles to
ten-year-olds
you walk into walmart they just give you
one
walk into walmart they did they just
give they're giving machine guns to
toddlers
that's exactly what i've heard
so this is the impression that he had
this is the this is the world that he
lives in
and yet he's a journalist and it's his
job to tell people about the world
except he's telling them about a
fictional world a world that exists
inside his head
my only regret is that this guy had not
gone to like a dollar tree
and gone to the toy section where they
sell if you can believe this
i mean at dollar tree and i've seen this
recently
they're selling grenades
at dollar tree
for a dollar
i mean they're plastic and they're in
the kid's toy section but
live grenades
um i guess they also what they don't
they don't sell toy i guess they don't
in the uk they don't sell toy weapons i
guess i'm not surprised by that
but that's journalism for you in the
year 2022. well
you've probably seen some of what uh
your kids are watching on tv and
learning in school hopefully you've seen
it marxism socialism critical race
theory in kindergarten through 12th
grade disney's recent directives to
degender children executives not so
secret push to
agenda to push non-binary slash
pansexual onto kids
scholastic kids magazine in schools
constantly rips on america you've
probably seen the viral videos of
parents begging school boards to stop
brainwashing our kids many of you are as
frustrated as i am parents
and upstanding educators are realizing
that most of america's school system has
been hijacked by the left and are now
committed to stopping radical agendas
from ruining our country
that's what prageru kids is all about in
just one year prageru kids has created
nearly 150 videos pieces of video and
print content for children in
kindergarten through 12th grade from
animated shows illustrated books to
digital magazines prageru kids offers
entertaining and educational content to
equip families to save the future of
america 300 000 parents teachers
grandparents and caregivers have already
subscribed to pragerukids.com
to get new episodes and resources
delivered to their inboxes every week
for free prageru kids offers what's no
longer being taught or celebrated in
schools and all the woke kid shows and
everything else and that is our american
values and history responsibility hard
work equality under god freedom critical
thinking truth innocence kids need these
values now more than ever get tons of
resources to watch at home and in
classrooms by downloading the prageru
app to your smart tv and devices go to
pragerukids.com right now enjoy their
animated shows books and magazines for
kids most importantly support prageru in
their efforts to get america back on
track subscribe now and don't miss
prageru's incredible free kids content
visit
pragerukids.com today
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
jim says i laughed out loud in my office
when his daughter addressed him as matt
referring to the story that i told about
my
pangender
child who was uh
very upset to find out that elon musk
was taking over twitter but um and i i
did say they're tr they're they're pan
gender you bigot
i didn't say anything about daughter
evan says nothing screams stuck in the
90s quite like talking about ending
hunger when the big problem is
obesity uh yeah i mean that's that's the
big problem in you know so to speak the
big problem in the united states and
much of the western world uh it's it's
quite the opposite problem from from
hunger as you point out
there still is plenty of actual hunger
and starvation and across the world and
third world countries and so on that is
a that's a
still a very real problem there are
people who are starving or famished
um the issue though is that as we
discussed yesterday um elon musk even if
he said i'm gonna take all of uh you
know all of my money and i'm gonna
i'm worth 200 billion dollars i'm going
to put it all towards ending world
hunger
he wouldn't even make a dent in world
hunger
because
so much of that in in so many cases
when you have hunger
it's not a simple lack of resources it's
not just like let's go buy a bunch of
food and give it to these people
it's that in many cases these are people
who are living under corrupt incompetent
regimes governments
that are causing this problem i mean
let's just take north korea for example
there are lots of starving people in
north korea
um
how's elon musk going to solve that
problem with
money it's they're starving because the
north korean government is choosing to
starve them
it's not that something they don't have
the resources they're just they're just
making sure that they're that their
people don't get those resources
and so what the this is this is what
happens when the u.n starts handing out
relief and and money and everything
um oftentimes it goes right into the
hands of corrupt
regimes and government officials who are
causing the problem to begin with
um
leroy says puberty makes everyone feel
weird lol i remember my best friend felt
weird because he grew like a foot in a
year yeah that feels weird he was gawky
for years his bones hurt as well
um and crystal agrees says i can almost
say with 100 certainty that every 12
year old girl that started her period
doesn't feel right it's effing normal
yeah and that's exactly the point i mean
for boys
i could say from experience
you know for boys puberty it's difficult
for any kid because your body's changing
so much
and uh for boys that's one thing where
you just you grow
you know you have to buy new shoes every
every two weeks and you're growing
really fast um for girls it's even more
difficult
which is why you could talk to
almost any
grown woman and they will tell you that
they went through something like this
you know when they were kids going
through puberty where they felt very
alien
in their own body
and um
it's just very fortunate for women who
are grown women today that none of this
stuff existed back then so they didn't
have anyone coming around and saying oh
i'll explain your feelings to you it
means you're in the wrong body
and here's the good news you can you can
have the right body a quote unquote
right body here are some pills
it's as simple as that
maximilian says matt the most heavily
discriminated against demographic in
public schools are by far left-handed
people
think about scissors discs and
handshakes
um yeah but you deserve it
left-handed people i i will say that's
that's one group of people who are
inferior
you freaks
you deserve everything that's coming to
you
if you haven't signed up yet for ben
shapiro's third thursday book club now
is the time to do it it streams tomorrow
night and ben will be discussing the
once and future king by t.h white the
book club will stream at 8 pm eastern
and you'll get to go through ben's notes
and have your most pressing questions
answered after the stream make sure you
pick up moby dick by herman melville for
next month's book club if you're not a
member yet head to third
thursdaybookclub.com to sign up and join
him next month for moby dick check out
the trailer
i want to tell you about my third
thursday book club this is not your
average book club these are the greatest
books in the history of western
literature
we're going to dive into the greatest
works of all time these are the books
that help form the key pillars of
western civilization and help define
america and we're going to do it live
with thousands of you our daily wire
members
i'm going to be your personal guide i've
read every one of these books i'm going
to draw out the important lessons and
themes from every book plus i'm going to
be answering your questions along the
way so we actually do read the book
together
you join the book club you are going to
get smarter you're going to get more
knowledgeable because this is an
investment in your most valuable asset
your mind the third thursday book club
it's going to change the way you think
you know when you sign up you'll also
get uh ben's notes which is a cheat
sheet to the important lessons of the
book so sign up now at third
thursdaybookclub.com to get his notes
sent straight to your inbox for the once
in future king by t.h white now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
as you know i am but a shy and
unassuming podcaster and i don't like to
be the center of attention that's why it
was so difficult for me yesterday when i
was the subject of a second round of
leaked videos
this time it was a meeting between
administrators and students at the
university of wisconsin-superior about
my event on campus which will be held
there tonight in fact
leftist students met with school
administrators to try to get the speech
cancelled uh they were unable to get the
speech canceled so far so they then
start to strategize their protest
against my speech school administrators
are more than happy to help facilitate
and plan
these demonstrations against me but
there's no systemic discrimination
against conservatives on campus remember
that doesn't exist administrators are
just conspiring with leftist activists
to protest conservative speakers but
that doesn't prove anything of course
so we'll watch some of these clips the
audio quality isn't great but it's clear
enough to get the gist
you don't need to hear it clearly given
that leftist activists only know about
five words in the first place so it's
not very hard to fill in the blanks but
let's listen
can you come back to this but getting
towards the
actual protesting
folks choose to do that what questions
are you actually protesting
um how like
how would you
approach or how did the protesters
um
uh
address counter protesters like if we're
sitting there like peacefully or
whatever that there are other people who
want to engage practice
how should we ask
the civil protesters
another group of individuals to your
point has the ability to
do that as well right so i think keeping
to the root cause of why you're
protesting
and what you're doing
and the purpose behind it sticking with
the core values
so the activist here is worried that
conservative counter-protesters might
get violent never mind that all of the
political violence on college campuses
and i mean
literally all of it is committed by
leftists
the administrators of course don't point
that out they don't say oh well as long
as you aren't violent then there won't
be any violence because you people are
the only ones who ever commit violence
instead they cater to the absurdity they
tacitly affirm these totally baseless
concerns
later in the discussion another
university official has an inspiring
message to share with the protesters
i think the power that you are
is in yourselves
you know one of the
the only people
that people have who don't have powers
so as a protesting group if there begins
to be any threats towards you i would
suggest all of you sit down
that will cause the scene
that will help joe and his
his officers know something has happened
and you will be in unity together
together so if somebody is getting
threatened sit down and call him
power was within she says as university
administrators continue their pep talk
to leftist activists but unfortunately
she's wrong i mean these people have no
power no strength within
as evidenced by the next and final clip
listen to this
but these actions reflect that you want
each other
and we will continue healing marginalize
on this campaign
it doesn't matter how much support that
you give if the culture doesn't take
this is one of the most exhausting
experiences of his life he says my
speech is one of the most exhausting
experiences
of his life
i'm the one who actually has to give the
speech and i certainly wouldn't call it
one of my most exhausting experiences i
have four kids i have like
50 experiences every day that are more
exhausting
but for him simply being in the vicinity
of my speech is exhausting the most
exhausting thing he's ever been through
which only goes to show just how coddled
and comfortable and spoiled his life has
been
and that's why just as i spoke directly
to the traumatized amazon employees
earlier in the show
now i i'm going to speak directly to the
leftist activists who will be protesting
my speech tonight and here's what i want
you guys to understand
that you rail against privilege but you
are the
epitome of privilege
truly you are the most privileged
generation to ever live on planet earth
you you've been shielded from discomfort
such that you that now you feel
personally attacked
if somebody expresses a contrary opinion
anywhere within a 50-mile radius of
yourself
you've existed within a protective
bubble that's only grown over time and
you wish that it will continue expanding
forever
you have to this point lived lives of
such extraordinary luxury that now you
feel entitled to remain ensconced in
this intellectual cocoon insulated from
viewpoints contrary to yon to your own
but
no such entitlement actually exists
at least it doesn't exist as a principle
of nature
it's not a natural right
your entitlement to psychological
comfort is a human construction a
harmful one
harmful to the world but harmful to
yourselves most of all
you know when you um
when you work with your hands or your
lift heavy objects
something that i'm sure you've probably
not experienced
your hands become calloused and the same
thing happens with your feet if you
spend a lot of time walking or running
something that again i'm sure is foreign
to you but the calluses are good because
they help you grip the heavy objects and
they protect your feet as you move
around your hands and feet are battle
tested hardened literally
calluses are also good because it's
shameful and embarrassing for a man to
have soft uncallused baby hands
well a similar thing happens
intellectually if you allow yourselves
to be challenged if you embrace and
welcome encounters with differing
viewpoints
then your ideas your worldview becomes
battle tested
calloused
firmer tougher
the more it's challenged the more it's
able to withstand challenges
but your worldview crumbles into a
million pieces if it even smells a whiff
of a challenge
a slight breeze can blow it over and
smash it into
bits that's why you're so afraid of me
and of anybody else who threatens to do
anything but
coddle you and whisper sweet nothings in
your ear
so
if my presence if my viewpoints cause
you discomfort exhaustion pain
i'm glad
that's a good thing
it will do you some good also
it will help you if you let it
and if you discover ultimately
that allowing your viewpoints to be
challenged
will destroy them
blow them to smithereens
and leave you just kind of standing
there
exposed
with your with with with the your entire
intellectual framework having been torn
down around you
well then that tells you something about
that intellectual framework it tells you
something about that worldview
if it cannot withstand the challenge
then then it needs to be abandoned
and you have to rethink everything that
you believe
and you could start doing that right now
otherwise i'm afraid to say
that you are
canceled and we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
according to the left elon musk only
wants free speech on twitter so he can
help out racists the economy slows as
the white house announces the
possibility of relieving student loan
debt and maybe increasing taxes and we
examine the mystery of joe biden's
missing millions that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen